ciao sì lo so che ci siamo lasciati ma
vorrei che tu mi ascoltasse perché c'è
una cosa importante che ti devo dire no
non sono assolutamente rapinata anzi ho
capito ho capito che era destino che ci
lasciassimo e io lo so benissimo che non
è solo col parlo perché entrambi abbiamo
le nostre colpe sono stati soprattutto
uno da sun tracciarli per la colpa tua
ma io non voglio discutere
non voglio litigare non parlo soltanto
con tutto quello che c'è stato tra di
noi si trasformasse in una bella
amicizia
e visto che siamo amici sblocca mi
predetta amici non ci si tiene bloccati
ed aver avuto bellini con questa vicenda
perché non c'è motivo di bloccarli sono
600 con nessuno è mari
[Musica]
quanto mi fa schifo
quando usciva con me diceva che la
odiava che era un oca senza cervello e
adesso ci riesce come se con altre due
ragazze
ma dico io impazzito e tu perché non me
l'ha detto prima dimmi subito nomi che
ne deve andare vedere col successo ma fa
schifo
ciao ciao mare volevo presentarti mio
nuovo fidanzato piacere essere molto
piacere si senti noi dobbiamo andare
dobbiamo sposarci ciao
e poi mi ha guardato e mi ha detto è
finita e sono tutta colpa mia se mi ha
lasciato
ho sbagliato tutto si era la mia vita io
non ne troverò mai che uno come twitter
è tutta colpa tia prova marina brava
allora come stai un sacco che non ci si
vede cosa mi racconti cosa è successo
agli ultimi mesi
tutto bene anzi guarda prima che mi
dimentichi che ho fatto un regalino
ferito compleanno anche se ci siamo
lasciati io tengo tantissimo a testa è
stato molto importante quindi ci tenevo
a farci avere questo regalo questo in
particolare è un libro molto carino e
molto romantico di marina che non so se
ti ricordi quella youtubers a chi guarda
con i video insieme delle copie delle
fidanzate gelose
ecco lei si realtà l'ho conosciuta a una
festa ma lei se sei proprio da youtuber
è anche simpatica molto carina in realtà
si e me l'ha regalato lei cioè
bellissimo regalo grazie
anzi siccome io l'ho già letto
bellissimo se vuoi che ti do del giro tu
scusa lei è arrivato il libro cioè siete
amici quindi adesso sì qualcosa di più
ci frequentiamo in realtà volevo dirti
ti da fastidio verona a me no ma
figurati cioè c'è comunque ci ha
lasciati già da tre mesi a lei normale
rifarsi una vita
non hai capito qualcosa hanno
assolutamente normali allora idea di
andare anche lo conosce rino amo ho
appena finito di staccarlo la situazione
questa la biondina che non ci convinceva
effettivamente è in qualche foto sua ma
dietro come se uno volesse nascondere e
qui gatta ci cova
sono andato a vedere suo profilo ma la
stronzetta ovviamente c'è la privato
quindi visto che nella sua biografia
dice vuole fare la modella io ho
utilizzato il mio vecchissimo account
fake quello dell'agenzia di moda per
contattarla e lei indovina un po con
boccato crede veramente in russia
invitando a un casting quindi adesso la
chiamerò il e estorto
però più informazioni possibili
ovviamente fingendomi un agente di moda
amo ne sono certa tempo tre o quattro
giorni e lui ritornerà da me mari
ma vi siete lasciati da tre anni ma cosa
c'entra il grande antonello dice che
certi amori fanno giri immensi ma poi
ritornano e lui ritornerà me lo sento
eccoti doveri e tutta la mattina che ti
aspetto ti sei dimenticato è che mi devi
portare a centro commerciale noi due
abbiamo tutte le domenica al centro
commerciale ma da due anni
niente non ci siamo mai lasciati mai
mettitelo bene in testa cosa è mio
adesso prendi la tua macchina e mi porti
al centro commerciale cosa guardi
livello
cosa ci fai a casa mia come non
traghettato mamma mi ha evitato per
pranzo potevo mica di rino alla mia ex
suocera preferita ve lo sai che mi adora
e poi la tua sorellina questa sera un
appuntamento galante e ovviamente aveva
bisogno dell'assistenza psicologica
della sua consigliera preferita
lo sapevi che usciva come un ragazzo non
è ovvio fatti due domande adesso tu mi
spieghi perché vai raccontare in giro
che mi hai lasciato tu perché è vero no
non è vero non è vero non dire cavolate
sono stata io lasciarti io ho detto a
sarà sei mesi prima che 2008 anziché di
volevo lasciare quindi sono state gli
occhi ma appunto tu hai detto sarà ma
poi sono io che l'ho fatto non cambia le
carte in tavola tua resto mai ai tuoi
amici e dici che hai sbagliato che
invece sostai a lasciarti tavolo ma
perché devo dire una stupidata
credo ci conosciamo come non mi
riconosci
così mi capisci credo che tutto
sbagliato persona dopo tutto il tempo
che è passato dopo tutto il male che
avete fatto tu non ti ricordi di me e io
non dimentico è io non lo dimentico che
mi hai tradito con emma della terza via
erano mangi male d'aosta e gli aironi
che piangevo avete tutte le bacio chiavi
dentro una fabbrica della fontina
eh sì dove mai bari ma raccontami un po
tu dei tuoi ex dai ex sì un ex ce
l'avrei avuto un ex no
in realtà no no no ex mono ex perché non
sono mai state fidanzate perché sono
single dalla nascita numero fare pesare
e non ci fai qui in marina cosa ci fai
tu scusami ci abito lo sai benissimo si
era dimenticato comunque tenuta qui a
fare un giretto senti perché non ci
perdiamo un bel caffè da tanto però
chiacchieriamo insomma guarda sono in
ritardo aspetta una persona chi quale
delle diciassette ragazze che ha
iniziato a seguire dopo che ci siamo
lasciati è emma la biondina o jasmine
che conosciuti discoteca conservi ancora
con me e ancora col proprio verificato
che si finge modella chi tiki tiki
quella che quale maledetti eccoci qui
marinara siamo arrivati alla fine del
video io vi ricordo che cuore corazza il
mio primo romanzo e lo trovate in tutte
le librerie su tutte le piattaforme
digitali
inoltre ricordatevi di seguirmi su
instagram perché comunicherò lì tutte le
date dei firma copie
spero tantissimo che il video vi sia
piaciuto mi raccomando fatemi sapere qui
sotto a quali di queste tipologie
appartenete e soprattutto se non l'avete
ancora fatto iscrivetevi al canale e
attivate la campanella vicino al tasso
d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre
aggiornati sui miei video io vi mando un
bacione enorme e ci vediamo al prossimo
video adoro
[Musica]